hey crazies the earth orbits in a nearly
perfect circle's it's simple regular and
reliable but not all orbits are like
that some of them can get really weird
this episode was made possible by
generous supporters on patreon ok let's
start with the basics the word orbit is
pretty broad it's defined as any path
where gravity is the only influence like
I said it's pretty broad wouldn't that
make freefall in orbit umm yeah yes it
would what I know it seems weird how can
this be in orbit it's a straight line
that starts and ends that last part is
where I think most of our trouble comes
from how can a path that ends be in
orbit I think it'll help if we imagine
what would happen if the earth didn't
get in the way this is just a portion of
a much larger path one that goes all the
way through the earth if we dig a big
tunnel and remove all the air then
there's nothing in the way the squirrel
will fall forever back and forth through
the earth that feels a little more like
an orbit doesn't it ok if you're still
not convinced it'll be more obvious if
we make a move sideways to say we
launched the squirrel off a building
using a slingshot introductory physics
tells us the squirrels path will be a
parabola but that's only approximately
true let's zoom out and launch him way
harder we can see now that his path is
actually a small portion of a large
ellipse an ellipse he would travel along
if the earth didn't get in the way
ellipses are very common orbit shapes
parabolas happen to just not near the
surface of the earth in fact using
newton's laws on a pair of objects is
called the two-body problem and there
are only five types of solutions for
those problems lines circles ellipses
parabolas and hyperbolas that's it just
five basic shapes lines are just
free-fall like the squirrel in the
tunnel circles and ellipses are what we
expect for planets orbiting stars our
moons orbiting planets even moons can
have moons we call the moon moons
parabolas and hyperbolas are the orbits
of things that zip in and then zip right
back out you know like that o Mulla
Mulla object everyone was all excited
about a couple years ago these five
basic solutions are what we call the
conic sections because they can be found
when a plane cuts through a cone they're
the solutions of the two-body problem
actually those are very realistic
Hughes's I know I know okay here's the
deal there is really no such thing as an
exact two-body problem we like to think
the Earth's orbit is only affected by
the Sun but it's also affected by the
moon that makes it a three body problem
this way it looks circular or at least
elliptical but if I exaggerate things
you can see these orbits aren't any of
the conic sections they're kind of wavy
gravity is still the only influence
though so they're still considered
orbits on the whole three body orbits
tend to be chaotic and unstable many
look like they have no pattern at all
some will collapse together to form one
big object others will throw an object
into deep space and become a two-body
system the vast majority of three-body
solutions are like this but not all of
them I mean the Sun Earth Moon system is
stable and regular right there must be
other stable examples and there are but
some of them are kind of unexpectedly
weird
we call these freefall orbits because
they act kind of like the squirrel
falling through the earth each object
moves along its own path but those paths
are not Luke's they're segments they
each have a beginning and an end will
they do that forever
sure well unless they get nudged by a
fourth object freefall orbits are
extremely sensitive they're like a tiny
island of stability in a sea of chaos
one little gravitational nudge and it's
all over which brings me to my next
point there's no such thing as an exact
three-body problem either if we consider
the entire solar system there's the Sun
the eight planets a bunch of dwarf
planets and countless asteroids and
comets
that's a many-body problem the early
solar system was a very chaotic and
unstable place things were moving all
over running into each other being
thrown out of the solar system the only
reason it's stable now is because the
big stuff that remains is pretty far
apart those vast distances make each
planet behave as if it forms a two-body
system with the Sun and that means the
conic sections work fairly well in the
short term but in the long term we have
to make some corrections the most
well-known of those Corrections is
orbital precession also known as the
precession of the perihelion I know
those are fancy names but but they're
actually not that complicated in an
elliptical orbit like this the
perihelion is the point where the planet
is closest to the Sun it's literally
what the word perihelion means but we've
already said that orbits are only that
simple in a two-body problem the solar
system is not a two-body problem even
though they're really far apart the
planets do tug on each other a little
those tugs are gravitational so the path
is still considered an orbit it just
makes the orbit process the perihelion
of the ellipse shifts around over long
time periods the perception it's really
that big four planets are wrong your
losses are fine thanks for the reality
check he's right as usual you'll only
see a precession this large around a
neutron star or black hole around a
normal star the shift is much smaller
you'd have to observe the planet for
decades before you'd notice this
precession happens with all of the
planets in the solar system but none of
them are as famous as Mercury's when we
measure Mercury's precession the shift
is 5,600 arc seconds
every century Oh what's an arcsecond
it's an itty-bitty tiny angle circles
are divided into 360 degrees right well
one sixtieth of a degree is called an
arc minute and one sixtieth of an arc
minute is called an arc second
that makes Mercury's 5,600 arc seconds
equivalent to a little over a degree and
a half per century since 360 degrees
would be one full cycle
Mercury's perihelion won't come back to
where it is now for twenty three
thousand one hundred and forty-three
years that's a long time we do have a
minor problem though when we consider
all the tugs with Newton's laws we only
predict mercury processes by five
thousand five hundred and fifty seven
arc seconds every century the prediction
is off by forty three arc seconds that
might sound small but it means the
prediction of the full cycle is off by a
hundred and seventy-nine years it cannot
be written off as a measurement error
unfortunately we'd have to wait until
1915 Ferb Einstein and his friends to
solve it we needed the general theory of
relativity or just general relativity
for short which says that gravity is
actually space-time curvature I've got
an entire playlist about it if you're
interested but here's the basic idea
gravity isn't actually a force that
pulls things together gravity is just
the name we give to the physical
distortion of space and time we still
call it gravity though so any paths
curved by that distortion are still
considered orbits it just tweaks the
rules a little bit so we can fix some of
the errors we were getting with Newton's
laws you know like that missing 43 arc
seconds of precession every century for
Mercury those types of errors while
important to fix are ordinarily pretty
negligible
99% of the things in 99% of the universe
obey Newton's laws to a high degree of
accuracy but sometimes things aren't
ordinary sometimes they're extraordinary
the craziest example being a black hole
which isn't actually a hole black holes
are
roughly spherical their balls space
space-time is so curved around these
things that some really weird happens
the path that light takes can get bent
too which leads to some very strange
optics if that light is close enough to
the black hole it can actually orbit on
a closed loop or even fall in just like
anything else a little further out even
the orbits of massive objects can do
unexpected things they can zoom in and
then out
whirling around as they go that's why we
call orbits like this zoom whirl orbits
actually this is really calming maybe
I'll just let it hey what what what how
what where was I right
black holes all orbits up to this point
have been planar that means each orbit
stays in its own plane but almost all
black holes are rotating and that does
even weirder to the orbits planar orbits
like this one are only possible in the
equatorial plane of the black hole in
that plane we can still find zoom whirl
orbits outside of that plane all bets
are off the space-time curvature pulls
the orbit out of the plane and into
three dimensions this is the weirdest
looking orbit that I can think
so how weird can orbits get pretty weird
actually we like to think of orbits as
simple conic sections circles ellipses
parabolas are hyperbolas but that's only
approximately true those shapes can
process they could have some waviness to
them they might look kinda like free
fall they could zoom in whirl like this
orbit around a black hole or they might
even do whatever this is it all depends
on how accurate you want to be and how
extreme you want to get so were you
surprised by any of these orbits let us
know in the comments thanks for liking
and sharing this video don't forget to
subscribe if you'd like to keep up with
us and until next time remember it's
okay to be a little crazy to everyone
overwhelmed by the last video yes I know
it was a very niche topic but I started
it over a year ago it was time to let it
go so I can move on to bigger and better
things hopefully today's video was more
to your liking and thanks for watching